I know how the solution you are
Nigeria's opposition either Peter Obi
tells his supporters not to lose hope
the labor party leader insists he won
Saturday's election and says he's going
to court to challenge the results I'm
not going away
walk through these documents
continued they
break
inubu of the governing all progresses
Congress was declared the winner by the
independent National electoral
Commission inec
for now the streets of the capital Abuja
and many other parts of the country are
calm as people wait for the court
process to play out legal challenges
have been launched before against the
results of presidential elections in
Nigeria but not more successful many
people are watching to see how
independent the Judiciary will be and
what proof opposition parties say they
have
some people did not vote because of
technical problems and a new biometric
anti-fault voter accreditation system
bring Nigerians who are experts
foreigners who are experts in electron
technology and tell us what happened on
that day you know I think that's a major
issue and it's an issue of trust
election is not about winning or losing
is about trust and legitimacy Nigeria is
Africa's most populous nation and the
continent's biggest economy many people
around the world are monitoring what
happens next here Al Jazeera Abuja